it's been promised forever but Beyond  Good and Evil 2 is finally on the way  I'm Tony and this is your long awaited  gamespot news update some concept art  has been teased on the game's facebook  page and creator Michelle on sales  Instagram account but Ubisoft has  finally confirmed that Beyond Good and  Evil 2 is in development the sequel was  first announced in 2008 but we haven't  heard much about it since promising a  new game is one thing but now we know  that Ubisoft's montpelier studio is  actually working on it we've heard talk  of beyond good and evil to a few times  now but it seems the studio is finally  committed of course Michelle on Sal is  currently working on wild so it might be  a while before we see the game in action  for now you can keep an eye on gamespot  for more updates and for all the news  about Ubisoft's upcoming games you're  already in the right place